es por esta comunicación a pesar que
tanto pensé como harris priorizaron no
cometer errores y evitaron las preguntas
más comprometedoras cómo podría este
debate vicepresidencial alterar la
dinámica de las encuestas de opinión a
26 días para los comicios del 3 de
noviembre
ustedes saben la campaña en los eeuu se
transformó severamente a partir de el
viernes de la semana pasada cuando fue
internado el presidente de donald trump
a partir de ese momento obviamente él
ocupó otra vez el centro de la escena y
si bien en los primeros sondeos surge
que era diferencia en el voto a nivel
nacional a favor de yo bailé bueno se
extendió significativamente en los
estados claves que van a definir la
elección tiene en cuenta el colegio
electoral todavía quedan dudas
significativas en particular en el
estado de la florida de arizona carolina
del norte pensilvania michigan wisconsin
es cierto que en la mayoría de ellos hay
una ventaja todavía a favor de bailén
pero en muchos casos esto no es
estadísticamente significativo síntesis
creo que ahora ha empezado una nueva
campaña mucho más polémica donde las
diferencias ideológicas políticas y
personales se van a evidenciar y creo
que recién tendremos una idea de como
sea
asignado las preferencias como se han
reordenado a la preferencia de los
votantes independientes al fin de esta
semana seguramente hacia el viernes
sábado el domingo esta semana tendremos
ya nuevos datos ya nos tocaba el tema
señor beinstein este debate confirma que
el ganador de las elecciones del 2020 va
a depender de la pandemia de el
coronavirus
la pandemia obviamente se instaló en la
agenda de la mente en los eeuu yo creo
que en ese sentido lo que estamos viendo
es que en los países donde hay
elecciones o aún donde hay debates
parlamentarios siempre polémicas
respecto de lo que han hecho los
gobiernos frente a este desafío
nadie tiene naturalmente una teoría al
respecto es un hecho absolutamente
novedoso y siempre hay críticas ustedes
pueden tomar cualquier país y siempre
haber crítica respecto de la política
desplegada en este caso en particular
pero que lo más importante es la
controversia generada la enfermedad del
presidente de trump el hecho de que el
pse fue un hospital apenas a cuatro días
de haber sido internado hay dudas
respecto obviamente de todo el
procedimiento empleado en ese sentido
del hecho que se sacó la mascarilla ni
bien llegó a la casa blanca
todas esas polémicas me parece que
resignifican la cuestión con él más allá
de las consecuencias económicas sociales
que han sido devastadoras en el mundo
entero
y este cara cara al ser más mesurado y
tocar temas polémicos como la migración
el aborto el cambio climático podría
considerarse más como un debate real lo
que vimos anoche
el debate de anoche fue indudablemente
de mayor nivel y menos interrumpido que
el debate presidencial que tuvimos él
desde la semana anterior creo que
también los protagonistas tienen estás
características son ambos mucho más
jóvenes y tienen creo yo una dinámica
más afín al parlamento recuerdo ustedes
que el vicepresidente may piensa antes
de ser el gobernador de indiana estuvo
en el congreso fue representante y fue
un repente muy activo se siente cómoda
la palabra estuvo en el periodismo
muchos años y obviamente cámaras a
grises muy conocidas por su habilidad en
el manejo de la palabra fue una persona
muy importante en california nada menos
como mística terminó y por supuesto
también el senado fue muy conocida en
todas las audiencias con jueces de la
corte con lo cual me parece que ellos
han expuesto esa habilidad discursiva en
el debate de ayer con mucho conocimiento
de política pública me parece fue un
debate de mayor nivel a pesar obviamente
los formatos de los debates televisivos
que limitan bastante la capacidad
argumentativa